who would your party like to see
legislation on this issue well I welcome
the decision of the employment tribunal
I mean uber is amazing technology it's
fantastic what they've been able to do
but the concern is if technology like
that transfers the obligations that we
expect to put on any good business to
the rest of us to taxpayers to the rest
of society in terms of paternity leave
and annual holidays sick pay well that
isn't a reasonable position to have so
it's about the balance between the two
things and I think it's an excellent bit
of work from the GMB trade union nobody
wants to see anyone in work we denied
basic employment rights so it's a step
in the right direction technology should
free yourself itchin should liberate us
it shouldn't leave us in a position
where we enjoy any less employment
rights and mr. Reynolds said could I
just get your view on that other issue I
was discussing with mr. Hynes there the
issue of disability benefits and how
they're going to look at increasing
support and targeting they say do you
think they should go a lot further and
have a look at overall at the cuts
coming down the line absolutely I mean
first of all I welcome the government's
recognition that they're getting this
wrong this is a system which has not
helped people it is put a lot of people
into misery and quite a lot of suffering
the fundamental problem is it's punitive
you know when people get a letter
through the door saying they're getting
one of these assessments they don't
think brilliant i'm going to access some
more support they live in fear of that
assessment because it doesn't take into
account the medical situation it's an
administrative test it doesn't usually
give them in a position where they're
getting more supportive it leaves them
in a position where they're getting that
financial support taken away and the
fundamental problem has been the
government the Conservatives they've
tried to do welfare reform not in a way
which gets people back into work but in
a way which saves money and that's gonna
be the big question they've got to
answer when they take this consultation
forward now let's get onto your own
patch the city now are sitting in the
middle of that at the heart of the Bank
of England is of course the governor at
the moment Mark Carney do you think
there's an operation to try and
destabilizing by the government well it
seems completely reckless I mean when I
read the story this morning that some
code Conservative MPs wanted to replace
Mark Carney with Jacob rees-mogg after
say that was the scariest Halloween
story I could have read I mean this is
deeply irresponsible if you look at the
the fall in the pound befallen sterling
how will that be helped by forcing the
governor of the Bank of England out this
is deeply irresponsible Mark Carney did
the right thing after the brexit vote he
pacified at the economy with the
measures that were taken conservative
MPs can't blame the Bank of England for
the poor performance of the economy over
the last six years they've got to take
responsibility for that and this is not
helpful in any way to the brexit process
or to the state of the economy as we get
close to the Autumn Statement would you
sound a warning that if a government is
seen to of forced out or at least put
pressure on an independent governor of a
major central bank that might worry the
markets yeah absolutely I mean this in
no way would help anybody in Britain it
certainly wouldn't help our economy the
operational independence of the Bank of
England should be sacrosanct John
McDonald said exactly that in his speech
earlier in the week of course
politicians we can change the Mandate of
the inflation target for the Bank of
England we can change the Bank of
England act but once we've got those
things in place that operational
independence must be respected and the
lusting this country needs right now is
more this chaotic irresponsible behavior
from Conservative backbenchers now what
I ask you about the Richmond by-election
coming up next month we expect more if
we are in November which are more or
less imagining coming up a first of
December anyway do you genuinely believe
that Labour should not stand a candidate
in that by-election to maximize the
so-called progressive vote well that was
a personal view we are going to stand a
candidate I thought it was something
that was worth consideration if the
local party were agreeable to that but
that's not the direction we've taken I
respect that so i'll be out campaigning
for our labour candidate once they're
picked it we're going to play a full
role in that by-election because you've
had I mean you've returned to the front
bench haven't you didn't think much of
Jeremy Corbyn a few months ago now
you're back working with him why the
vault fast well it's brexit in the main
I think the brexit process is going to
be something completely fundamental to
my life to anyone who lives in Britain
now and in the political process for
many years to come and I'm deeply
worried I'm genuinely deeply worried by
what we've seen from the Conservative
Party so far not just this forcing out
the governor of the Bank of England
story but the messages we sent out on
foreign workers the failure to say EU
national should remain here we
to be now talking about a
sector-by-sector may be a factory by
factory brexit deal that's not the way
to get the best result for this country
in that process this negotiation has to
be scrutinized in parliament and of
course I want to play a part and I think
that's what any MP needs to be doing
right now and just tell me as shadow
City Minister and what kind of soundings
are you taking in the city the mum you
having a lot of lunches and a good
reception can you tell me who you've
been to see yes I've had quite a good
time in the city so far obviously the
sea isn't just a square mile in Canary
Wharf but I spent being an MP in London
in the weed quite a bit of time there
I've been to see the Bank of England and
the governor I've been at the guildhall
I've talked to many people so far and I
can genuinely tell you people tell me
they have never before had so little
confidence in a conservative Prime
Minister on the economy with the
anti-business rhetoric they're coming
out with and they are very scared about
what they've heard so far about the
brexit strategy the government seems to
be adopting and they want some more
detail from what the way forward will be
well what city businesses have you been
to see said the Guildhall on the bank of
england what about the ones that make
the money there yes I've been to see
some of the banks some of the asset
management organizations and people in
insurance and I've had a very good
reception from people I did anticipate
that's a question people would want to
ask of any new shadow City minister but
i can tell you I've spent a lot of time
there and I'm very much enjoying the job
so far as we salute hastens messing with
the ceiling time walking around or you
actually been letting the door which
ones have you seen mr. Reynolds that
were I've been to see people from
Barclays I've been in talks with people
from the financial conduct authority
I've met the governor of the Bank of
England I met the chief economist of the
governor of the Bank of England so
there's been a very wide open door to me
it hasn't been the case that people
haven't been willing to talk to labour
about this they want to work with the
opposition and they want this to be a
successful process for the country we've
got to get bricks it right